well let's talk about Oprah she's
bringing tens of thousands of people
around the country together with a
mission to make their lives better so
she kicked off her national tour in Fort
Lauderdale this weekend she brought
along a few familiar friends we got
exclusive behind-the-scenes access at
the first stop on the 20/20 wellness
tour why because we know Amy wine Blum
and Oprah of course one of the world's
biggest pop stars Lady Gaga was there
Oprah and Lady gaga
discuss physical and mental health so
when I say we got exclusive access I'm
talking about David bag no we we drew
the lucky straw I think David we got to
go along to see Oprah and Lady Gaga in
action I haven't seen you in the last 48
hours what a weekend it was such a
weekend we've been working on this piece
all night long I can't wait 12 hours of
edit so here we go can't wait good
morning to you my friends 20/20 vision
your life in focus is what the tour is
called it's presented by w w formerly
known as weight watchers the tour
started as an idea that oprah had after
she invited nearly a dozen people who
had lost a lot of weight over to her
house in Hawaii to celebrate that's what
inspired the tour which started in
Florida to a sold-out crowd
[Applause]
fifteen thousand people packed into the
BB&T center in Sunrise Florida on a
Saturday morning ready to live their
best life with Oprah and I hope that you
leave here today with a sense of being
connected to the answer of what is the
more for you take me to the key
Oprah's 20/20 vision tour is a campaign
to promote wellness we are doing this
with 15,000 people in a sold-out arena
I know that our desires are the same we
all want the truest highest purest
expression of ourselves seven hours of
what felt like group therapy with
thousands of strangers and it was
strangely comfortable the day started
with insight motivation and a little bit
of homework I'm trying to see how y'all
are doing here
everyone was challenged to test the
balance in their lives using a workbook
that rated them on movement nutrition
and purpose among other things
my 2020 vision is to get rid of those
fears that I now at Weight Watchers
it was Oprah's intention to partner with
WW the company formerly known as Weight
Watchers
it was started on Long Island by Jean
Medich who wanted to lose some weight
and did it with a community of women who
she would invite over to her house they
would weigh themselves that was 57 years
ago I loved the new my WW program
Oprah is now the largest shareholder in
WW but long before she had an ownership
stake
she says the point system that the
company uses helped her realize that
living well isn't about staying home and
starving yourself so when each tour stop
Oprah highlights local restaurants that
offer WW meals the Colgate's
owns low greenhouse grill in Miami there
WW menu item is shrimp and collard
greens they thought we were just
stopping by for a taste no once Nicole
caught her breath she served us some of
Chef Kareem's tasty shrimp and collard
greens which yours truly had never had
before very good as we say in Louisiana
sauce a ball
very good it was sauce a bomb good
sometimes women of color who are in a
certain financial situation don't feel
like they have access to these yes yes
so in order for you all to in court
bring us in when they can walk across
the street and actually sit down dine
with dignity with their families and be
a part of a national program like Weight
Watchers makes the world just a little
bit smaller part of wws push is wellness
that involves working on your mental
health
one of the biggest champions of mental
health education is lady gaga
we stopped by to speak with us before
taking the stage
I know kindness is your mantra Chinese
heals all things it is the most powerful
weapon that we have interpersonal Gaga
got very personal with Oprah
I will put my shame in a box all the way
over there and make it very small hmm
and say to myself I have mental health
issues I take a lot of medication to
stay on board and I'm a survivor
and I'm living and I'm thriving and I'm
strong and I'm gonna take all my life
experiences and I'm gonna share them
with the world and make it a better
place
Wow so many in the crowd were recording
with their cell phones as Lady Gaga
candidly revealed how she deals with
pain daily and she says it's caused by
fibromyalgia
a medicine called carbonic called The
Lancet me and I took a few other things
that are stress based but I want to be
very careful about say any of this you
know in a public way to tell anyone what
to take you know this is not it's not
the same for everyone and that is the
kind of real talk which Oprah is known
for getting from celebrities who remind
us that we are connected through our
struggles and with that the first stop
on Oprah's nine city tour was over
thoughts on the whole day my thought of
the whole day is wow this is
unbelievable I think this is this is so
incredible it makes me really want to
cry makes me want to cry that people
care so much that they would come out
and they would give up their Saturdays
and do this what is your intention for
every person who comes I hope people
leave with the rising and them because
you know I know that you can't come to a
motivational speech or day and instantly
change your life
but I want people to feel the rising
inside them that yearns for the more and
then have clarity about what that more
is oh they felt that let me tell you so
the interview with Lady Gaga will air on
Oprah's Facebook channel and the WWE now
Facebook channel this coming Wednesday I
was there and I'm like god I want to go
to that and it's going to Minneapolis
next week she's and she's doing nine
cities but Oprah was emotional Gaga was
emotional and you see the two of them
together
Gaga talked very candidly about being
raped about being bullied you can see
that on Oprah's Instagram it's worth
going to see the two of them together
just sort of rehashing what happened on
that day tawny she was so piercingly
personal yeah it wasn't expecting to get
that from Lady gaga she almost came
somewhat humbled you know it wasn't the
big shock in all performer that you used
it
made her so relatable yeah a so so human
she was very fragile didn't you think
that was very fragile on the stage and I
think Oprah does that in terms of
bringing people out and that's really
what she wants as we all go into 2020 to
figure it out what what propels us what
makes us happy and how do we achieve
that and it's so much more than weight
wellness on this particular tour is a
very big part of the state of mind yes
it's not your grandmother and
granddaughters Weight Watchers anymore
this is a whole new ballgame
David thanks nice job David very nice
job
you